y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las
principales noticias las más destacadas
de nuestro continente relacionadas con
la pandemia del cob y 19 a continuación
les presento el sumario de temas que
tenemos para el programa de hoy vamos a
hacer foco en la región de centroamérica
con nuestros corresponsales en las
ciudades de sanjosé managua y san
salvador- conoceremos cómo está
avanzando la pandemia y también
conoceremos en detalle los efectos de
las medidas impuestas por los
respectivos gobiernos veremos también en
detalle cómo están avanzando las
negociaciones de los gobiernos de la
región de américa de también de la
región de américa latina para comprar
por adelantado lotes de vacunas que
están en desarrollo contra el hobbit 19
abriendo paso a la que ahora califican
como la diplomacia sanitaria y nos
iremos hasta bolivia allí como medida
desesperada para hacer frente a la
pandemia han propiciado el comercio sin
regulación del plasma hiper inmune
aprovechando que hay una gran necesidad
por parte de los ciudadanos y que hay un
vacío legal
y estos y otros temas que a continuación
vamos a desarrollar en este programa
vamos a comenzar hace casi seis meses
que el coronavirus ya llegó al
continente y particularmente a la región
de américa latina y desde entonces ha
provocado cerca de 250.000 muertes solo
en la región de américa latina también
ha aumentado la pobreza en una región
que ya de por sí era desigual y ha
afectado el progreso económico y social
que habíamos tenido en varias décadas
brasil perú colombia y méxico son los
países más afectados por la pandemia del
joven 19 a continuación les presentamos
un panorama general de la situación en
nuestra región
con más de tres millones y medio de
contagios brasil es el segundo país en
el mundo con más casos de ccoo y 19 sin
embargo la propagación del coronavirus
podría estar a punto de desacelerarse
por primera vez desde abril la tasa de
transmisión de kobe 19 se está
desacelerando en brasil según datos del
centro de control de epidemias del
imperial college de londres la tasa de
contagio en brasil fue de 0,98 un número
que indica a cuántas personas puede
contagiar un paciente infectado del
coronavirus los trabajadores de la salud
insisten sin embargo en que la aparente
ralentización no es motivo para suavizar
las medidas preventivas como el uso de
mascarillas y el distanciamiento social
pero es el segundo país de américa
latina en la lista de los más
contagiados a nivel mundial la nación
andina superó el medio millón de casos
positivos por lo que el gobierno
actualmente coordina la compra de 30
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
jove 19 con 5 laboratorios extranjeros a
finales de agosto comenzarán los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna de la
de oxford con voluntarios peruanos
méxico está por detrás de perú en la
lista regional de contagios de 1 millón
211 mil 552 pruebas aplicadas para
detectar el coronavirus el 45% han
tenido un resultado positivo uno de los
golpes más duros para méxico así como
para el resto de países ha sido en su
economía el trabajo informal es elevado
y son estas personas las que más han
sufrido en los últimos meses
bajar la venta
cerrar colombia le sigue a mexico en la
lista bogotá donde está el foco de la
infección ha tenido que implementar
varias cuarentenas obligatorias por
localidades lo que ha detenido los
contagios levemente
con el avance en el desarrollo de las
posibles vacunas contra el cob y 19 tema
que ya hemos analizado en este programa
también ha comenzado ahora la llamada
diplomacia sanitaria y son esas
negociaciones que están avanzando entre
los países particularmente con los
países desarrolladores de la vacuna para
poder obtener dosis tan pronto como sea
confirmada la efectividad de la vacuna
hay muchos países que ya han cerrado
negociaciones millonarias con los
laboratorios veamos algunos de los
países de nuestro continente eeuu por
ejemplo que es el país más afectado en
nuestro continente ya cerró una
negociación cercana a los 100 millones
de vacunas 100 millones de dosis y le
apostó precisamente a la industria local
a un laboratorio de eeuu a la
farmacéutica moderna que es una de las
que se encuentra ya en la fase 3 para el
desarrollo de una posible vacuna el
gobierno de perú un poco más en la
región de suramérica también ya confirmó
que destinará entre 245 y 400 millones
de dólares para comprar una vacuna esto
le permitirá acceder a unas 20 a unos 30
millones de dosis
y el tiempo también que indicó que
dependiendo de los avances que tengan
las diferentes farmacéuticas definirá
con qué laboratorio se vaya cuál le va a
comprar estos 30 millones de dosis
uruguay que es uno de los países
aplaudidos de la región allí el gobierno
también dijo que tiene ya entre sus
planes la adquisición de unos 2 millones
de dosis también está por definir cuál
sería el laboratorio elegido para llegar
a conseguir este tipo de vacunas por su
parte colombia que es uno de los países
más afectados de la región el ministerio
de salud de ese país desmintió una
información que salió esta semana en
este país que indicaba que ya habían
comprado 16 millones de dosis de una
posible vacuna que está desarrollando la
farmacéutica pfiezer las autoridades
allí en bogotá indicaron que no era
cierta esta información y que el país
todavía está estudiando las diferentes
opciones porque entran en juego en los
tratados comerciales que tiene con
algunos países de la unión europea y
también con eeuu
y la extracción y la transfusión del
plasma hiper inmune de pacientes
recuperados del cob y 19 se ha
convertido en un negocio de primera
línea en bolivia pese a la prohibición
de la venta del plasma la desesperación
por una forma de prevención de este
virus ha desatado la donación desmedida
de sangre así como la compra también de
la misma todo un mercado al margen de la
ley esto lo que está sucediendo
una nueva mercancía en alta demanda las
redes sociales de bolivia están llenas
de anuncios de búsqueda y oferta de
plasma hiper inmune es decir el plasma
de recuperados del cob y 19 hay quienes
piden hasta 1500 dólares por someterse a
una extracción de 600 mililitros el
comercio está prohibido pero las
autoridades no pueden evitarlo el
diputado boliviano amílcar barral estuvo
cerca de morir por causa de el
coronavirus obtuvo una donación de
plasma pero no fue suficiente y tuvo que
pagar 600 dólares por un segundo
tratamiento
mi hermano logró encontrar a un donante
por así decirlo
vendieron a cuatro mil bolivianos
con este plasma más logró reforzar más
mi
la dejé en las defensas en mi cuerpo y
demás y comenzó las operaciones
el diputado propuso una ley para que una
persona curada en hospitales del estado
se comprometa a donar plasma pero el
parlamento optó por fomentar la
solidaridad aunque hay miles de
recuperados el principal hemos centro de
la paz no ha recibido muchas donaciones
siempre nos hemos sido más por el lado
solidario por el lado altruista de las
personas no de que puedan realmente ser
voluntarios y poder donar de manera
voluntaria por amor al próximo
lamentablemente en nuestro país no se ve
tal amor
janet que prefiere mantener su nombre
completo en reserva perdió a su padre
por falta de plasma ahora ella quiere
ayudar a una persona en concreto
haciendo una donación yo pase lo mismo y
no me ayudaron y las personas que
quisieron quisieron lucrar con el plasma
y era demasiado de mucha cantidad y hay
personas desesperadas que no pueden
conseguir les estafa no les asaltan la
transfusión de plasma sanguíneo ha
salvado muchas vidas pero es aún un
tratamiento experimental probado en los
más grandes hospitales del mundo
la región de centroamérica representa
todos los escenarios posibles en esta
pandemia países con un altísimo número
de contagios con respecto a su población
como es el caso de panamá la imposición
de medidas que junto a un buen sistema
de salud como costa rica han servido
para mitigar ese avance desenfrenado del
virus o también países donde el gobierno
simplemente decidió no tomar medidas
como nicaragua o donde también el exceso
de precaución no les ha ayudado como
esperaban acaso el salvador incluso hay
países que han sido aplaudidos por la
comunidad internacional por su manejo de
la crisis como es el caso de belice
vamos a analizar la situación que se
está presentando en la región de
centroamérica con nuestros
corresponsales en sanjosé managua y san
salvador vamos a comenzar con cindy
regidor en la capital costarricense a
olas indie y la llamada segunda ola está
afectando un poco más fuerte a costa
rica este país cerró esta semana con un
récord de contagios que pues claramente
no se había presentado allí y tiene en
alerta a las autoridades costarricenses
hola santiago así es esta semana
nuevamente hemos presentado una cifra
récord en un día de casos nuevos esto
preocupa a las autoridades la mayoría de
contagios son en la zona urbana
alrededor de la capital y también en la
frontera con nicaragua en donde se
encuentran empresas productoras
agrícolas especialmente de piña es decir
que estas dos son los principales
lugares o focos de contagio actualmente
el país ya lleva más de 30 mil casos
registrados pero sí
sigue siendo uno de los países con las
tasas de letalidad más bajas con
solamente el 10 4% si el gobierno ha
implementado otro tipo de medidas para
hacer frente a esta segunda ola ya hemos
visto que costa rica ha sido un país que
le ha hecho frente desde el principio de
la situación haciendo
adelantándose un poco a que la situación
se le fuera a salir de las manos pero
ahora con estos rebrotes que se están
presentando qué medidas hay nuevas
así es actualmente el país tiene algunas
zonas en alerta amarilla con mayor
flexibilidad de movilización y otras en
alerta naranja con mayor restricción de
movilidad además en este mes han habido
un par de semanas con apertura parcial y
también un par de semanas con cierre
parcial el presidente carlos alvarado ha
dicho que cada vez menos el mensaje será
quédate en casa y ahora se pasará al
mensaje hay que aprender a convivir con
el virus pero si tomando las medidas y
los ruidos necesarios
si este país tiene un punto a favor y es
el sistema de salud ya lo hemos
analizado acá es un sistema robusto un
sistema universal que tiene
prácticamente cobertura en todo el
territorio costarricense está muy bien
equipado y los tomo no por sorpresa como
si le pasó a algunos países en el sur
américa con esta segunda ola como están
haciendo frente está la saturación de
las ucis en unos porcentajes bajos como
está la situación hospitalaria
elpresidente alvarado ha dicho que las
medidas fuertes de cierre que se tomaron
al inicio ayudaron mucho a ganar tiempo
y también equipar a los sistemas de
salud para que pudieran aguantar una ola
como la que estamos viendo actualmente y
aunque sí ha habido preocupación porque
se satura el sistema sanitario eso
todavía no ha ocurrido y de hecho la
seguridad social en 5 meses ha logrado
aumentar su capacidad de camas
disponibles de unidad de cuidados
intensivos de tan solo 24 ahora habría
de ser necesario la capacidad de más de
280 camas
cindy en las últimas semanas estábamos
viendo los problemas de salud que había
con inmigrantes inmigrantes
nicaragüenses que llegaban a la frontera
norte de costa rica- trataban de entrar
muchos de ellos contagiados con el virus
del cob y 19 también hay algunos
ciudadanos cubanos que están en su
camino por intentar llegar al territorio
estadounidense y están en este momento
estancados en costa rica cuál es la
situación de ellos ahora le pregunto
porque sé que usted estuvo allí en el
punto fronterizo y pudo ver de primera
manu cuál es la situación y cómo se ha
resuelto allí el caso de estos
ciudadanos cubanos y nicaragüenses
en el caso de los ciudadanos
nicaragüenses que fueron más de 500 hubo
una situación de crisis humanitaria
estos nicaragüenses son migrantes
económicos que no tenían la capacidad de
hacerse una prueba de kobe di que su
gobierno tampoco se las ofrecía
ni a cambio de un pago ni tampoco de
manera gratuita por lo que pasaron hace
15 días parados ahí a la intemperie como
podemos ver en las imágenes y finalmente
lograron entrar por la solidaridad de
las organizaciones de sociedad civil que
coordinaron la realización de las
pruebas en el caso de los cubanos que
están alrededor de 300 como ya lo decías
algunos han solicitado refugio al
gobierno costarricense mientras que
otros permanecen ahí y aseguran que
únicamente quieren entrar para transitar
hacia eeuu el gobierno de nicaragua sin
embargo pues mantiene una posición
rotunda de no dejar entrar a las
personas que no portan la prueba
negativa bueno ese es el panorama que
tenemos en costa rica nos vamos a ir un
poco más al norte hasta el salvador allí
está en la capital salvadoreña vladimir
chamorro vladimir ha habido un descenso
activo en el número de contagios y
también en el número de víctimas allí en
el territorio salvadoreño cuáles son las
cifras y son medidas exitosas las que ha
tomado entonces el presidente bucl
santiago pues efectivamente después de
tener muchos días cerca de dos semanas
con un alza feroz y galopante con más de
400 casos llevamos ya 10 días con una
con una reducción importante y ahora más
o menos promediamos o esta semana
tenemos un promedio de cerca de entre
200 y 250 casos el ministro de salud ha
dicho de que esto ha permitido desahogar
los hospitales públicos y hay más de
1.500 camas disponibles y personal
médico ya listo para atender nuevas
emergencias que puedan surgir esto han
dicho que se debe prácticamente a la
buena gestión que están haciendo de
parte de parte de las autoridades para
atender las pandemias sin embargo
especialistas como el presidente del
colegio médico ha dicho de que hay un
subregistro
oficial y que este podría ser hasta
cinco veces mayor allí en el salvador
vladimir también avanza la reapertura
económica una reapertura digamos un poco
accidentada porque ha habido muchas
discrepancias entre el gobierno los
empresarios la corte suprema- los mismos
ciudadanos cuál es la situación allí en
torno a este tema y cómo avanza esta
apertura
sí bueno estamos en la fase 1 de la
reapertura económica empezó desde junio
a raíz de controversias no se definía el
inicio de la fase 2 y las subsiguientes
fases de la reapertura económica esto se
resolvió con un fallo de la corte
suprema que da vida a un decreto del
legislativo el decreto 661 de la
reapertura económica o que ordena la
reapertura económica entonces a partir
de eso la sala ordenó al presidente en
allí bukele para que sancione dicho
decreto y lo mande a publicar en plazo
estamos hablando que tiene ocho días
para sancionarlo y quince días para
publicarlo en el diario oficial de no
ser así el presidente del congreso
tendrá las facultades para hacerlo
esperamos que esto se resuelva antes del
24 de agosto pues si no se resuelve el
24 antes del 24 de agosto quedaría es en
ese tiempo descubierto y podríamos no
hay un respaldo legal para el orden el
ordenamiento de la reapertura pero en
principio esperemos que se resuelva con
buena voluntad y el presidente luego
logré
y publica el decreto en los términos
fijados por la sala de lo constitucional
de la corte suprema de justicia la
divida todo este panorama que es difícil
como lo es no solamente para el salvador
sino para todos los países de la región
de centroamérica se suma también una
preocupación que tienen ahora las
autoridades y es el incremento del
número de embarazos no deseados en este
país centroamericano que dicen las
autoridades sobre este tema qué cifras
se están manejando entonces
ok santiago si un reciente informe de la
organización de mujeres salvadoreñas por
la paz hermosa daba un dato sumamente
preocupante y es que en el primer
semestre del 2020 ellas registran más de
6000 menores de edad con embarazos no
deseados estamos hablando de más de 250
niñas de entre 10 y 14 años y más de
6500 menores entre los 15 y los 19 años
esto pone en evidencia la fragilidad del
abuso sexual
y los embarazos no deseados en la
sociedad salvadoreña y también pues pone
de manifiesto el nivel de impunidad que
existe dentro de la legislación
salvadoreña pues estos casos
generalmente suceden dentro de los
hogares y nunca son llevados
a instancias legales por su parte las
autoridades de salud contradicen estas
estas cifras diciendo que han disminuido
pero la organización feminista pues lo
que plantea es que estas denuncias no
han llegado hasta instancias del
ministerio y por lo tanto no existe ese
registro pero pero bueno ahí está ese
dato que es muy muy muy muy preocupante
que estamos hablando de más de 6000
menores con embarazos no deseados y
muchos de ellos productos de el abuso
sexual claro que son cifras aclaro
vladimir de embarazos que se han
registrado y abusos que se han
registrado a lo largo del tiempo del
confinamiento es decir desde que empezó
en la cuarentena obligatoria y en el
salvador por eso la preocupación en este
escenario no solamente particular del
salvador hay muchos países de
centroamérica y también de américa del
sur que están presentando incrementos en
el número de embarazos y también de
violencia doméstica finalmente para
terminar vladimir terminó con otro tema
económico importante y es que el
gobierno hablo de la reapertura del
aeropuerto internacional del salvador
que es el segundo hub de conexiones más
importantes
de la región tiene muchísimo tráfico
entre el norte de suramérica
centroamérica hacia estados unidos y
canadá y es un punto importante para la
economía salvadoreña que han dicho al
respecto
bueno las autoridades gubernamentales
han planteado de que el próximo 4 de
septiembre el aeropuerto internacional
óscar arnulfo romero iniciaría
operaciones a un 35 por ciento es de
destacar como tú lo has planteado de que
este es una de las terminales aéreas más
importantes de la región pues es el
centro de conexiones para centroamérica
de la aerolínea avianca además dar
servicios también a aerolíneas que
vuelan a más de 30 destinos en
centroamérica sudamérica europa entonces
es una importante noticia para la
reactivación económica esto permitirá
que también poco a poco se esté pensando
en la reapertura del turismo una de las
fuentes de ingresos más importantes para
el país y para las economías locales
sobre todo de las zonas costeras del
país esto sin duda será un impulso
importante para el sector turismo y
económico un punto importante para la
economía salvadoreña siendo de alguna
habla del mir nos vamos ahora hasta
managua allí se encuentra jorge hurtado
vamos a analizar la situación de este
país jorge comencemos por las cifras hay
discrepancias entre las cifras que está
dando el gobierno del presidente ortega
y las cifras que dan los organismos
internacionales y también algunas
clínicas e instituciones allí en managua
cuáles son las cifras que se están
presentando y por qué hay esta variación
estas discrepancias en torno a los
números así es ateo bueno mientras del
gobierno reportó esta semana que hay al
menos 4.000 casos confirmados de kobe 19
el independiente observatorio ciudadano
que éste es una plataforma creada a raíz
de la poca información pública respecto
al desarrollo de la pandemia y nicaragua
y que dirigida por sociedad civil
denuncia que en nicaragua los casos
confirmados rondan los 10.000 y que las
muertes superan las 2.600 en contraste
con las 130 fallecidos que reporta el
gobierno de daniel ortega para críticos
del gobierno el secretismo o la poca
información que se ha revelado respecto
a la evolución de la pandemia nicaragua
se debe a una estrategia de parte del
gobierno para minimizar el impacto
económico que podría tener 1.019 en
nicaragua
y esto es algo que ha reconocido el
presidente ortega le ha dicho que se
tiene que convivir con la pandemia y ha
invitado a los ciudadanos a continuar
expone con todas sus actividades
regulares sin ningún tipo de restricción
también a lo largo de esta semana
trascendieron jorge que el grupo de
hackers anonymous hackeó e información
del ministerio de salud de nicaragua y
dio a conocer información que como usted
decía
hace parte de este secretismo del
gobierno que fue anunciado allí que dato
fue revelador de este hallazgo que
hiciera bueno según un anónimo y según
la base de datos que ellos filtraron a
la oposición y especialistas que también
las estudiaron hasta el 24 de julio
pasado el gobierno habría realizado una
que x 7 mil 249 pruebas de kobe 19 y de
ésta unas 9 mil 683 resultaron positivas
o confirmadas lo que representa un 56
por ciento de estos casos es importante
señalar que más de 1.000 corresponden al
personal sanitario y esto también va en
sintonía con la denuncia que han hecho
durante los últimos meses parte del
gremio médico y la oposición
nicaragüense denunciando la muerte de
más de 100 sanitarios fallecidos por
poder decir de esta semana daniel ortega
habló a la nación y en parte de su
discurso mencionó que ha habido cierta
situación al personal sanitario del país
pero no especificó cuántos fallecidos ni
cuánto del personal sanitario
ha sido infectado por el coronavirus
jorge hablemos de la vacuna la semana
pasada el gobierno anunció que la o ms
había incluido a nicaragua en ese
listado
a los que les donará la vacuna que sea
desarrollada contra el hobbit 19 pero
también el gobierno de nicaragua dijo
que estaba interesado en desarrollar y
en distribuir desde managua la vacuna
sputniks 5 que es la vacuna
la controvertida vacuna desarrollada por
rusia qué novedades hay en torno a ese
tema
bueno el rosario murillo quien es vocera
y esposa de amil ortega y también ha
dicho que nicaragua va a producir esta
vacuna a través del instituto
latinoamericano de biotecnología llamado
mexico y que además de producirla para
el consumo de los nicaragüenses
inclusive podrían estar la exportando a
la región de centroamérica respecto a
esta planta se sabe muy poco fue
inaugurada en 2016 recientemente uno de
esos funcionarios declaró a medios
afines al gobierno de que durante este
tiempo en esta planta rusa han estado
desarrollando vacunas para la infancia
insulina y también en vacunas contra el
rotavirus este lavado y laboratorio ruso
tomó relevancia en marzo cuando inició
la pandemia acá en nicaragua porque
también dijeron que
estarían desarrollando el medicamento
cubano y peter feroz alfa donde algunos
especialistas dicen que es imposible que
este laboratorio éste pueda tener la
capacidad de desarrollar esta vacuna y
que las promesas no se tratan más que
propaganda política de parte del
gobierno
jorge nicaragua es uno de estos países
en donde el gobierno optó por no tomar
ningún tipo de medidas preventivas los
ciudadanos son los que han tomado sus
propias medidas como está el día a día
sobre todo allí en la capital en managua
cuál es el comportamiento cuáles son las
medidas de bioseguridad que hay allí
bueno en las calles se ve una relajación
ciudadana que para algunos especialistas
podría retornar en algún tipo de rebrote
en los próximos días los ciudadanos
están saliendo a realizar todas sus
actividades y sin duda este discurso
oficial de promover las actividades que
se continúen con una especie de
normalidad en paralelo con la pandemia
ha calado en la población también nos
confirman los datos de movilidad de humo
y las personas están saliendo más
inclusive algunos comercios que habían
decidido cerrar en marzo debido a la
pandemia han anunciado sobre la apertura
iglesias evangélicas que también habían
estado clausurado durante estos últimos
meses han convocado
a sus seguidores a que retornen porque
van a realizar una reapertura en los
próximos días y esto mantiene en
bastante inquietud a los especialistas
quienes advierten que podría esta
relajación ciudadana generar un rebrote
de coronavirus en el país pues a
nuestros corresponsables allí en estas
tres capitales centroamericanas muchas
gracias por este análisis por actualizar
nos en torno a la situación y como están
haciendo frente allí a la pandemia cindy
vladimir y jorge muchas gracias por este
completo informe vamos ahora hasta la
ciudad de nueva york que como ya lo
habíamos visto ha sido uno de los focos
principales de contagio a lo largo de
esta pandemia en eeuu particularmente
los barrios de inmigrantes la mayoría de
ellos latinos afrodescendientes y de
bajos recursos fueron los más afectados
de acuerdo a un estudio recientemente
hecho en esta ciudad el 50 por ciento de
los residentes de estos sectores ya
tienen anticuerpos es decir ya
padecieron el coronavirus
damián a reyes ha vuelto al trabajo pero
su mente a menudo deriva hacia su padre
quien sucumbió al coronavirus a los 76
años vivían juntos en queens un distrito
de nueva york y es justamente allí donde
se encuentra el barrio que registró el
mayor número de casos y muertes por kobe
19 en la ciudad hombre resulta casi
irónico corona en ese vecindario muchos
que conozco lo tuvieron al menos diez
personas en mi calle contando a mi padre
amargado en esa zona mayoritariamente
hispana y de bajos ingresos un 51% de
las personas sometidas a pruebas de
anticuerpos dieron positivo una tasa muy
por encima de la media de la gran
manzana y el virus sigue dejando huellas
en el barrio axilas filas para obtener
comida gratis se hacen más largas día
tras día en su mayoría hombres latinos
que perdieron sus trabajos esta es una
lucha todos los días para nuestra
comunidad en la zona y lo único que
podemos hacer en este momento para
ayudar es darles algo de comida
si bien tal es la realidad en los
barrios menos favorecidos en los más
acomodados las tasas son muy inferiores
el permanente abuso y la permanente
agresión racismo y discriminación de
esta administración
hacia la comunidad inmigrante y
especialmente latina yo creo que le hizo
mucho más vulnerable y le hace mucho más
vulnerable sin embargo las elevadas
cifras de cero prevalencia en algunos
vecindarios de la ciudad es decir la
manifestación de presencia del virus
apuntan a que buena parte de su
población ya habría pasado la enfermedad
lo que podría ayudar a controlar una
segunda oleada
y el caso de perú sigue preocupando a la
comunidad internacional a pesar de que
las autoridades se tomaron medidas
tempranas como el confinamiento adecuado
en la red hospitalaria y también
pidieron el uso de las mascarillas entre
otras la cifra de contagios y de
fallecidos sigue fuera de control para
agravar esta situación se habla de un
gran desfase en cuanto a los números que
indican que el panorama puede ser peor
en perú podría haber hasta el doble de
muertes por kobe 19 y es que las casi 26
mil muertes que ha registrado distan de
las más de 50 mil por coronavirus de las
que habla el sistema informático
nacional de defunciones que es el
registro oficial de todas las muertes en
perú el ministerio de salud aseguró este
fin de semana que antes del miércoles se
entregará la revisión de sus cifras lo
que sería el tercer ajuste desde abrir
la cartera creó un grupo independiente
para estudiar las muertes sospechosas
por kobe 19 y el primer cambio llegó en
julio
tendríamos 13 mil 767 personas
fallecidas y a esto luego del análisis
que ha hecho este equipo vamos a añadir
tres mil 688 personas fallecidas el
segundo ajuste fue hace cinco días y el
equipo independiente sumó otras tres mil
668 muertes a los registros del
ministerio de salud dra
con lo que perú superó los más de 25 mil
decesos aunque las estadísticas siguen
lejos de las del sistema de defunciones
algunos aseguran que la realidad
con el colapso de ciertos centros de
salud en el hospital que hay inaugura
del presidente de vizcarra el hospital
temporal ya colapsó las 100 camas ya
están llenas incluso hay pacientes que
están en el pasadizo esperando desde el
día de ayer su atención la ministra de
salud ha explicado que el desfase de las
cifras se debe a que el ministerio no
incluye en su reporte público las
muertes sospechosas y por qué no todas
las estadísticas de los gobiernos
locales llegan al ministerio peruano
colombia superó la barrera de medio
millón de personas contagiadas con kobe
19 y cierra la semana con más de 500
13.000 personas confirmadas con este
virus
este registro este país registró el
primer caso de contagio el 6 de marzo de
2020 en junio ya los números rondaban
los 40 mil casos y en agosto ya este
país como ya lo dijimos superaba los 500
mil casos lo que representa un aumento
del 1200 porciento en solamente dos
meses aún así el gobierno ha mantenido
un des confinamiento con excepciones
dando origen también a una de las
cuarentenas más largas del mundo
y nos vamos ahora hasta nuestra sección
en redes veamos otras noticias
destacadas de esta semana comenzamos con
esta publicación del director general de
la uem es el etíope pedrós adán
domínguez ver es jesús quien nuevamente
hizo un llamado para evitar los
nacionalismos en torno a la masificación
de la entrega de vacunas el funcionario
indicó que está trabajando con los
gobiernos para que las vacunas sean
entregadas para estas personas que más
lo necesiten
y en colombia el presidente iván duque
dio la bienvenida al primer vuelo de
pasajeros autorizado dando así inicio al
restablecimiento parcial del sistema
aéreo en ese país el mandatario recibió
en el aeropuerto internacional josé
maría córdova de rionegro que sirve a la
ciudad de medellín un avión turbohélice
en donde arribaron también algunos
funcionarios del gobierno la
reactivación estará prevista de forma
plena para el mes de septiembre
y de acuerdo con un reporte de la oms
uruguay y guyana son los únicos países
de sudamérica que no tienen transmisión
comunitaria del cob y 19 aún así están
presentando brotes cuba jamaica y belice
en el caribe y en centroamérica tampoco
están presentando transmisión
comunitaria que es el escenario más
complejo para combatir el coronavirus la
república oriental del uruguay ha sido
aplaudido a nivel internacional por el
manejo que le ha dado a la pandemia
solamente tiene unos 1500 casos
confirmados y 41 personas han fallecido
hasta el momento
y esta semana volvieron a reabrir el
acceso a los visitantes al emblemático o
cristo redentor ya el cerro del pan de
azúcar en la ciudad de río de janeiro en
brasil eso sí con muchas estrictas
medidas de bioseguridad para evitar
aglomeraciones y contagios
como si se tratara de una inauguración
el ministro de medio ambiente brasileño
junto a miembros del gobierno y de la
iglesia cortaron la cinta que simboliza
la reapertura del cristo redentor
así le está trabajando en una reapertura
segura cuidando principalmente de la
salud y la supervivencia económica de
las personas
antonio lugar mayor disco sobrevivencia
económica antes de la llegada de los
turistas nacionales y extranjeros las
autoridades realizaron una limpieza
profunda en todas las áreas del lugar el
distanciamiento social el uso de
mascarilla y la desinfección de las
manos son medidas obligatorias para los
visitantes lo mismo ocurrió en el cerro
de pan de azúcar donde los turistas no
faltaron para la reapertura siempre
vamos a estar preocupados pero desde que
se cumplan todas las medidas nos
sentimos un poco más seguros tenemos que
dar pasos para poder volver a la vida
normal poco a poco los famosos
monumentos brasileños han recurrido a
los descuentos en las entradas para
atraer visitantes en medio de la
pandemia de coronavirus
me encanta necesitábamos esto todos
estábamos nostálgicos pero tenemos que
salir con mucha cautela respetando la
distancia social evitando las multitudes
siguiendo las reglas de la organización
mundial de las unidades visitar estos
lugares significa un respiro para el
turismo de la ciudad carioca y también
para aquellos que buscan distraerse sin
embargo las autoridades sanitarias
aseguran que brasil aún no ha alcanzado
el pico de contagios más de 3,3 millones
de personas han dado positivo a la
prueba de kobe 19 ya supere las 107 mil
muertes a causa del brote respiratorio y
así llegamos al final de este resumen
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa
dejen sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales nosotros
nos volvemos a encontrar la próxima
semana hasta entonces
[Música]